what did you make of Bill Clinton's
comments that Obamacare was a crazy
thing oh yeah that was a little crazy is
the campaign going to be able to keep
him from going rogue now he was saying
it was crazy that people had qualified
for the subsidies and then in between
which Hillary had talked about having a
way that they could get into the health
insurance - he's praised Obamacare of
gazillion times he did not say that but
their carrier but I mean let's be honest
as long as the profit motive is still in
the equation it's never really going to
work I mean it's gonna work people are
gonna have more coverage than they
should but as long as you you cannot
stop it on one end of the equation that
is people can charge as much as they can
these the EpiPen you know I mean this
this kind of what a profit comes despite
it's even working Vermont yeah they
tried it in Vermont they couldn't make
it working better than before
no they compared Vermont no but what we
have what President Obama has done with
the Democrats pass it not may not be
working as well as you want is working
better than the system they have
enforced uninsured rate drop the bomber
care was one of the most important and
most difficult startups of all time
course but you have to understand it's
still a start-up right and any big
company like that any big startup like
that I'm gonna have issues and you've
got to improve it and they will it's not
just that it comes back to what we were
talking about the tax code part of the
problem is the big pharma companies by
the system they give to both sides the
first thing that happened on the first
day of the Obamacare negotiations is
they agreed they were never going to
negotiate on prescription drug prices
because they were in debt to those
companies everything you say is true if
everything you say is true it is true
they're more people insured today
a lot more oh no let's take let's take
some good news okay let's take some good
news and you're right the
pharmaceuticals of our still don't
retire but the effects are good
[Applause]
we're here to talk about issues not
getting this isn't the lollipop our
giving good level tell them say
something nice about alright let's look
at this is mr. positive over here
alright that's good as I said to him
yell up some good news alright pitbull
why did you get involved in the charter
school movement
oh I mean for the simple fact that it's
real simple a lot of people are not
we're talking about right now no we're
talking about a lot of things as far as
change and you know when it comes to
politics and politician I call it
politics I think it's a lot of [ __ ]
they say a lot they do a lot of a whole
lot of nothing so when it comes to the
kids if you're able to tap into a young
mind teach you how to believe in itself
focus work hard inspire it motivated
then guess what they're able to grow and
make educated decisions so therefore my
mother always told me the biggest
diseases in the world the two big cities
in the world
ignorance and greed which we see was
suffering from it right now with Trump
running as we speak you know I want to
be able to show these kids hey as you
get older at least you know the decision
you make you can stick by it because you
know where you were well informed let me
push back a little on something I said
there about Paulo Trix
it is probably what they do is nothing I
think that's a very dangerous message
because that makes people just turn off
and go oh they're all alike they're all
full of [ __ ] actually here in California
we have a Democratic governor and we
have a Democratic legislature so we've
been able to do great things when
politicians actually want to work
together and you have the right ones
they do things and that's a reason why
we have Medicare before before that yeah
I still think the full of [ __ ] to be
honest with you Bill well no but but you
know what maybe make me a maybe from the
different side of traction oh so there's
a it engine to do what I wanna take note
and the Devils in the details and I know
it is one [ __ ] cousin to be honest
with you but with that said but the
place is what I'm trying to tell you
look when politicians they come out they
talk a hole got a you know a great game
and mine you're we're talking about
climate change you talking about what
they did for California with all my
California's what is in a drought right
now I'm on don't like one let me just
tell you something before before Lyndon
Johnson came along and you know this
better than I do and passed Medicare
senior poverty old people who lived in
poverty because they didn't impinge
stuff was something around 40% it
reduced it to something like nine okay
that's what she will change that's
something I already speak about because
I don't know the details on that
that is what I'm telling you even think
about what it is then don't say they're
all full of [ __ ] and they don't do any
political about the [ __ ] majority of
them are full of [ __ ] yeah what well
then don't vote for those that's right
but you don't you have to learn who to
vote for
that's the thing because that says if
they all full of [ __ ] then Hillary and
Trump are equal I met today in fact it's
very Jane not awakened mondo what Bill
is saying how you can relate that mini
or full of [ __ ] I'm with but majority
understands that their majority of them
full of [ __ ] and I just think that but
lot of tickets become a propaganda as we
see it right now i watch Hillary and I
watch Donald Trump and it looks like the
[ __ ] WWF Hogan in are you a genuine
facilities man it's not because it's
something to make charter schools that's
yeah that's what you're saying about
charter schools I'm afraid is the
[ __ ] Lee or you're denouncing you
know you look at the places in the world
that have schools that are doing really
well they do the opposite of the charter
school privatization model think about
Finland what they do is their best
schools in the world
they [ __ ] pay their teachers really
well that's what we should be
[Applause]
150% with you by the way and if you were
to look into our model our teachers are
very well in centralized but this is
more than anything this is about
flipping education and in making it
exciting for the kids show up at the
countries now I agree now charg'd
undergraduate school system that places
that succeeded have done that without
the pocket rotation and everything you
need some human is exciting yeah
correct and that's why we flipped it
with with with sports that's what we
flipped the curriculum if we're talking
about data data analytics in it and
they're in algebra or geometry whatever
maybe they'll do um they'll do fantasy
football they'll do if it's XYZ then
we'll do a 60 yard line X amount of time
on the clock and they need this many
points like we find a way to make it
exciting we flip the curriculum so I
it's called slam sports you sorry I
great but you've got to do that within
the public system not the same and it's
not this is the knowledge system
trondheim because say 92 percent of the
kids in my school on free lunch my
friend sure these are all the ones that
come from the neighborhood that I come
from which is Little Havana my friend
because they're adding a conference
individual charters I look hey you know
I come from a neighborhoods they don't
talk about it be about it Putnam that's
all ya know Co the pit bulls good no no
no so I'm so not hey if you want look at
numbers they'll cover y'all want to see
him you know he's not gonna bite he'll
hump your leg but even yeah
got my girl talking about nothing
Oh Oh or mondo nobody here listen to
this right now your governor in Florida
Rick Scott
oh man huge [ __ ] okay how did he make
his money
Medicare cheating so a state with mostly
retired not mostly but like the largest
Rajendra Pachauri elect a guy who
cheated all people a state that is in
danger of global warming elected a
global warming denier and part of
Obamacare is a Medicaid expansion that's
part of it Republican governors blocked
it now when they voted for the governor
last time if they had voted Charlie
christen he would have been down with
the Medicaid expansion and something
like 800,000 people in that state would
have gotten health care 800,000 people
don't have it because they elected this
[ __ ] and that really the devil is
really in the detail you're right and it
affects pernicious I will openly if
somebody needs health care now all those
people they cannot get and one thing on
my end guys I want you to understand I'm
a person that came from nothing to
something I really don't understand a
lot of things I'm learning as I go and
I'm kind of person that admits when I'm
wrong I'm the kind of person that admits
when I don't know certain things and I
get thrown in the world of politics you
know I get thrown in this world because
they feel like they they want to you
know pull in our culture and they want
to obviously they go for that vote just
a lot of things that I'm learning as I
go and I'm always there for advice but
one thing I am is very very passionate
so that they'll let me it's like a point
I just want to make sure you guys know
that I'm far from perfect walking
and I just watched you just in my state
in Louisiana which is very poor state
one of the poorest take you out we had a
government that did not expand Medicaid
we had hundreds of thousands of people
that needed insurance that didn't have
it we elected a new governor and he did
it he changed people's life it is not
the same right I get what you're saying
what you're saying but they just gave
you look it's a disk it's so easy just
sit back and no oh they're all crooks
and they're all liars and they're all
this but actually when you and when you
elect the right people like a certain
lady who's running you know their focus
really they may have their foibles we
all do we have to recruit from the human
race none of us are perfect
some of us use the wrong email server oh
my god but basically this is a person
who her whole life is focused on how can
I make people's lives better Lee better
I there are those people out you saw the
dangers of the degeneration of the
debate this week when it came to the
reaction to the vice presidential debate
Tim Kaine made a really important point
which is that Donald Trump thinks a
there should be more nuclear weapons in
the world and B it should be easier to
use them and the reactionary one was God
didn't Tim Kaine sound like a whiny
[ __ ] I cried
wasn't he annoying I'll tell you what's
annoying dying in a nuclear explosion
yeah that would be significantly more
likely if the god--all drown I couldn't
agree more when you tell them more
serious discussion is why I love doing
this show right and the idiot media is
like well Mike Pence won the debate
because his demeanor was better his
demeanor was better but he lied his ass
alright what if there's a thing and
that's something called you wouldn't
notice but I think the other thing Carla
is commandment what I think there's
something about thou shalt not lie about
you think that was like that's once at
East command mail the age
Kali's but i think they came in the
kitchen like the whole time in brighton
people media said did he get great he
can see just why he's a so it was there
was some time is he speaking Spanish I
don't know and just to say what I feel
more no I understand hey I'm just
learning you know it is I can't
understand you cuz I smoke too much
[Applause]